[Music]
Parisian Couture could influence how
thousands of ordinary women dream and
live but fashion needs a new
leader I fig your
head
[Applause]
m I keep looking for the great
collection to Rise From the Ashes of
[Music]
the what do you desire to design the
most beautiful women's cloth that ever
existed your ruin French kuu and I'm
coming back to save
it for those of us who lived through the
chaos of
War creation was
survival the legend of Coco Chanel if
people only
knewest Chanel can be very treacherous
oh yes heart are you happy with the
revolution you
started there is the truth my mind is
but there is always another truth that
lives behind it she's not safe creation
cannot stop the bullets but creation is
our way forward our choices
matter my
legs use my
head use my heart your heart will be
magnificent you think J is
special real talent is turning your life
into something
[Music]
bigger people need to Fe here dream they
need to live again we can create a new
world for
[Music]
them